durant with me kevin before the series
steve nash said that you guys have to
overcome
your newness have you accomplished that
no i think we still got a long ways to
go um this is an amazing team on the
other side who i know
and on their whole floor they're going
to come with it so we have to too and
we just did what we supposed to do was
win two games at home what do you think
you've learned about yourself
i mean we uh you know we play hard we
play together
you know then good things happen for us
tomorrow
will mark two years since you initially
injured your
calf i know you worked your butt off to
get to this point but did you ever think
you'd be
this good is that a real question
of course what you want me to say to
that of course i mean
it's pretty impressive what you've been
able to do thank you i appreciate that
but i mean that was two years ago i'm
looking forward to just
getting up tomorrow and going to
practice watching film and uh
and seeing how we can get better but you
know i appreciate that but you know that
was that was too long ago
all right well i'll come up with some
more real questions for you next time
thanks kevin